[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام احييكم وهذه الخامسه
مشاهدينا
صحيفه امريكيه تكشف عن امتيازات تقدمها
السلطات الايرانيه للمنضمنه لحمله قمع
الاحتجاجات
كيف تطور مسيرات قتاليه واشنطن تتحركوا
لمنع حصول طهران على مكونات تصنيع
المسيررات
طوكيو تستعد لاستيراد اول شحنه من النفط
الروسي معفاه من سقف السعر في استثناء ان
غربيا نادر
واستقاله جماعيه للاستا بجامعه كابو
الاحتجاجا على قرار منع النساء من العمل
والتعليم الجامعي
اذا المشاهدين نبدا الخامسه من ملف
الاحتجاجات في ايران والاساليب التي
يتبعها النظام في قمع الاحتجاجات
المتواصله وذلك منذ منتصف سبتمبر الماضي
تقرير لصحيفه وول ستريد جورنال تحدث عن
اعتماد السلطات على الالاف من المؤيدين
المخلصين اللي وقف الاحتجاجات الشعبيه
المستمره منذ اكثر من ثلاثه اشهر الصحيفه
الامريكيه افادت بان الاف المخلصين الذين
تستخدمهم الحكومه يشكلنا الحرس الثوري
والمليشيات الاخرى الاقل رسميا الصحيفه
اكدت انه وبناء على استطلاعات للراي
اجرتها مؤسسه غير ربحيه ومقرها هولندا
اكدت ان واحدا من اصل خمسه ايرانيين
يدعمون النظام
ايه ده المشاهدين وحسب ما ذكرت صحيفه
وستريد جورنال فان النظام الايراني يوظفوا
للالاف من الموالينا لقمع المحتجين لكن من
هم هؤلاء المؤيدين له كيف يحافظوا النظام
على اخلاصهم وفقا للصحيفه الامريكيه فان
هؤلاء العناصر يشكلون الحرص الثوري
بالاضافه الى حزب الله الايراني
والمليشيات الاخرى الاقل الرسميه ومعظمهم
من خلفيات متواضعه اقتصاديا ومحافظه
اجتماعيا للحفاظ على الوضع الراهن
تستدرجوا وتغري طهران هؤلاء الناس من خلال
الامتيازات والوظائف والاسلحه من جانبه
قال الباحث الايراني بجامعه تانسي سعيد
جوكر قال ان عمليات جمع المواليد تبدا من
سن المبكر وذلك في معسكرات الاطفال ونوادر
الاحياء فئران تهيئ شباب من عائلات
المحافظه للانضمام الى البسيج تقوم
بتدريبهم على المبادئ الدينيه وجهات
المنظر الحكومه المعديه للغرب الباحث اضعف
ان الشباب المولين يحضن بالاولويه في افضل
الجامعات الايرانيه مما يضعهم في صف
المناصب الحكوميه العليا
هذا ولا تزال الاحتجاجات متواصله في
العديد من المدن والمقاطعات رغم سياسه
القمع التي يمارسها نظام ايران في حق
المحتاجين والذين بات مطلبهم الوحيد
والرئيس هو رحيل النظام ورحيل رموزه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هذا وقت شدد مكتب رئيس الوزراء البريطانيه
ريش السوناتا على ان بريطانيا لن تقبل
ابدا باعتقال مواطنيها كوسيله الضغط
دبلوماسيه وطلب مكتب سوناتا طلب ايران
بوقفه ممارساتها غير العادله والاعتقالات
التي تستهدف مزدوج الجنسيه حظ مكتب سوناتا
ايران على الافراج عن المحتجزين
البريطانيين والذين يحملون جنسيات اخرى
افادت صحيفه تايمز بان اداره الرئيس
الامريكي جو بيدا اطلقت جهودا واسعه
النطاق لوقف قدرتي ايران على انتاج وتسليم
طائرات بدون طيار الى روسيا ووفقا
لمقابلات اجرتها الصحيفه مع مسؤولين
مخابرات والامن القومي
الامريكيين فان اداره تهدف الى خنقي قدره
ايران على تصنيع على الطائرات المسيره
اشارت الى ان من ضمن هذه الاجراءات حرمان
ايران من المكونات الغربيه الصنع اللازمه
لتصنيع المسيرات بعد ان تبين انها موجوده
في حطام الطائرات التي اسقطتها اوكرانيا
اوضح احد كبار المسؤولين العسكريين الذين
تايمز ان الشراكه بين روسيا وايران في
مجال المسيرات تعمقت كثيرا بهدف انقاذ
بوتن بحسب الصحيفه
على كل المزيد معنا من لندن الباحث
السياسي الايراني دكتور مهرداد خنسااري
اهلا بك دكتور اسمحلي هلا لدينا ايه تفسير
عن كيف تستطيع ايران ليس فقط انتاج هذه
المسيرات ولكن حتى تصديرها الى روسيا رغم
كل العقوبات يعني بمعنى اخر باختصار من
اين لك هذا
الاعتبار ان برنامج المسيارات في ايران هو
شيء
سمسميه الليل
[موسيقى]
اي اكثر من 30 سنه من الخبره
في مجال المسيارات وانتاجها
فاصبحت جزء اساسي من الاهداف الدفاعيه
الايرانيه
وفي اليمن او لبنان او فلسطين او سوريا او
اي مكان تزودهم بمثل هذه المسايرات هذا
الامر المتعلق بروسيا هو جديد
ومساله
معقده وبرنامج
متطور والغرب دائما كان يحاول ان يفهم او
اييي يحد من قدرتهم على الحصول على
الاجزاء والقطع التي تلزمهم لانتاج مثل
هذه المسايرات كانوا ناجحين ومن الصعب
ايقافهم
وايقاف هذه الشبكه لتصنيع المسيارات
يعني يمكن فهم اهداف ايران التي ذكرتها
ممكن فهم منه ت الخبرات حتى وصلوا الى هذه
التكنولوجيا كما ذكرت 30 عام ولكن عندما
نتحدث عن قطع غربيه كيف لها ان تصل اليها
في ظل العقوبات وهذا هو السؤال السؤال
الاكبر ليس كيف صنعت ليس كيف تعلمت ليس
كيف حصلت حتى على قطع من اي دوله اخرى
ولكن قطع غربيه
ان هناك سوق سوداء همم نشطه جدا في سوق
بيع السلاح بشكل عام
وهمم وايران لديها خبره جيده في هذا
المجال همم مع ثمان سنوات من الحرب العراق
وكانت مبيعات السلاح بالسوق السوداء وكان
يحصلون على اي سلاح يحتاجونه
همم قد يدفعون همم ضعف او ثلاثه اضعاف
الثمن لكن يحصلون على السلاح ويصلون الى
مثل هذه المواد المتطوره
فمتطلباتهم في هذا المجال من الحصول على
القطع التي يحتاجونها سهل وهناك كثر يمكن
ان يتجنبوا العقوبات وسياسه العقوبات
وهيتحايل عليها
ويوصل هذه الخطاب ليس من دول تحترم
العقوبات ااه وليس فقط الروس او الصين
هناك كثر يمكن ان يتعاونوا معي ايران ليس
بمساله سهله همم
فعندما يقول تقول اوروبا وامريكا ان تزويد
روسيا لهذه المسيرات في انتهاك للقرار
للامم المتحده اثنين اثنين همم ثلاثه فهذا
هذا ليس صحيح
هذه مساله
يصعب وقفها وقف ايران في هذه المرحله
الصحه دكتور بس في سؤال في ما يتعلق بما
ذكرت ذكرت انه الموضوع ليس سهل وربما غير
ممكن فيما يتعلق بخنق ايران كما تقول
الاداره الامريكيه وبالتالي عن ماذا تتحدث
هي عندما تقول بانها اطلقت العنان
للخيارات الموجوده الان
لوقف هذا التصنيع ووقف هذا ايضا التصدير
اعتقد اننا علينا اخذ الاخذ بالاعتبار ان
بقاء هذا النظام
بقدره همم
النظام على انتاج شيء يستطيعون الوقايه به
يعطيهم قوه
تفاوديه هذه المسيارات تستخدم يستخدمه
الحوثيين وحزب الله هم بحاجه لها
كي يتمكنوا من التفاوض بموقفهم في سياسه
الاقليميه
ويبيعونها ايضا لروسيا كي يكون لديهم همم
معامله تفضيليه من روسيا عندما يحتاجون
الى روسيا فطالما هذا النظام موجود
يصعب جدا رغم المظاهرات قد
تصعب جدا احتواء تطور تورطهم في مثل هذه
النشاطات لان هذه افعل
يتعلق بها بقائهم من لندن الباحث السياسي
الدكتور
مهردات شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
قلى وزير التحول الرقم الاوكراني ميخايل
لوفي دروف ان بلاده تهدف الى تطوير طائره
مسيره قتاليه جو جو في المرحله القادمه
المسؤول الاوكراني اكد ان الطائرات
المسيره ستعمل على صد الطائرات المسيره
المتفجره والتي تستخدمها روسيا في الحرب
اوضح الوزير في لقاء مع وكاله الاسوشيات
بريس ان اوكرانيا اشترت حوالي 1400 مسيره
معظمها لمهام الاستطلاع وستعمل على
تطويرها لهذا الهدف ووصف فيدروب حرب روسيا
بانها اول حرب كبرى في عصر الانترنت وعزل
الفضل الى الطائرات المسيره وانظمه
الانترنت عبر الاقمار الصناعيه كاستار
لينك في احداثه تحول في الصراع لصالح
اوكرانيا
المزيد معنا منك مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل
اهلا بك حذيفه بدايه اي معلومات اوف حول
هذه الطائره المسيره المستهدفه من قبل
اوكرانيا لتصنيعها
لابد ان نبدا في ذكر ان الشعب الاوكراني
او المهندسين الاوكرانيين يمتازون
بخبره كبيره
وهم مميزين في سوق العمل في الجانب
الالكتروني والجانب البرمجي وهذا ما يعول
عليه السيد الوزير في مساله تطوير الطائره
هنالك كتيبه الكترونيه انضمت للجيش
الاوكراني هي من المتطوعين من الخبراء ومن
المهندسين الذين يعملون على تطوير العمل
في الجيش على تطوير البرمجيات والاجهزه
والالكترونيه في الاتصال وما الى ذلك وهو
الذين يقومون الان في منطقه تحديدا يقومون
بتطوير هذه الطائرات هذه الطائرات هذه
الطائرات صينيه تم شرائها طائرات استطلاع
تم شراءها من قبل الجيش الاوكراني يعملون
على تطويرها بالفعل قاموا بتطوير طائره
هذه طائره الان تقوم اختبارها اوليه هي
تقوم اولا هي تستطيع التحليق
الذهاب الى مسافه 25 كلم تستطيع ان تقوم
بمناورات تستطيع ان تقوم بمهام قتاليه
ولكنها اختبرت اختبار اوليا والان تم
الدفع بها في صفوف القتال المتقدمه الى
احدى الكتائب من ما يسمون بالكتيبه
الالكترونيه
لتجربتها في مهام قتاليه همم
تحت التجربه في جدول زمني متى الانطلاقه
الحقيقيه والاعداد اللي قادرين يصنعوها او
تطويرها على الاقل
لا في الحقيقه لم يتم يعني الافصاح عن اي
جدول زمني ولكن هم الان ينظرون الى
امكانيه وقدره هذه الطائره عن العمل في
درجات تحت الصفر هذا اولا والثانيه قدرتها
على المناوره هذا اهم يعني الان يتم النظر
اليهم في تجربه هذه الطائره في مهام
قتاليه في الخطوط الاماميه بعد ذلك تبدا
عمليه تصنيع واسعه همم هذه الطائرات
القيام بمهام كتاليه واعتراض طبعا
المسيرات الايرانيه همم اخر التطورات
الميدانيه حذيفه
نعم يعني اولا كريمنا في منطقه لوغاز كما
زالت هي الوجهه للجيش الاوكراني يضغط بشده
على هذه المدينه يحاول السيطر عليها اليوم
اسر جيجا ايضا تحدث عن تقدم للقوات
الاوكرانيه للوصول الى هذه المدينه كما
قلت سابقا وما زال الوضع كما هو علي ان
هذه المدينه تعتبر هي تقرا في خط دفاع
الجيش الروسي اذا ما استطاع الجيش
الاوكراني يفوز منها يستطيع بسهوله الوصول
الى صفاته والوصول الى ايضا سيفر جينيسكو
الشمس ولكن هنالك الان خطوطين ينظر اليه
من الجيش اوكراني اما التقدم الى سوبر
ديسكو اما تحول هذه القوات في هذه المنطقه
للمساعده مساعده القوات التي تقاتل في
منطقه باخ موته اليوم ايضا رئيس
الاستخبارات العسكريه الاوكراني عن خطوط
اماميه في باخوت في المدينه نفسها وتفقد
الجنود هناك وما زال المحاور الثلاثه
الايمان الاسد
عن الكهرباء والماء هل في تحسن حذيفه وعلى
الاقل في العاصمه ام ماذا
تحسن طفيف في العاصمه كيف يعني استقرار في
جدول القطوعات اصبحت الكهرباء تقطع مرتين
في اليوم في ولا يزيد عن اربع ساعات بعد
ان كان الضغط على 20 ساعه في اليوم ولكن
هنالك ما زالت بعض الاحياء ليس في المدينه
وانما في الولايه كيف في بعض المحليات في
هذه الولايه ما زالت تعاني من بعض المشاكل
ما زالت لم يصل اليها التيار الكهربائي
وكذلك المدن الممتده في الشرق
التي يصعب الوصول اليها ايضا ما زالت
تعاني من انعدام للخدمات بما فيها
الكهرباء ولكن الوضع يتحسن كل ما ذهبنا
غربا الى الولايات الغربيه
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المعلومات
نبقى في الملف الاوكراني وفي اول زياره
لاوكرانيا منذ بدء الحرب وصل وزير الدفاع
الفرنسي سباستيان
طبعا زار الوزير الفرنسي نصب ضحايا الحرب
الاوكرانيه مع روسيا رفقه وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني والكسي رزقوف ويتوقع ان تشهد
الزياره اعلانا فرنسيه عن تقديم ما بين
سته الى 12 متدفع سيزار من عيار 255 ملم
تضاف الى 18 مدفعا من الطراز نفسه كانت
باريس قدمتها الى كيه منذ بدايه الحرب
في موسكو اكدت الرئاسه الروسيه ان اي
مباحثات او خطط للسلام مع اوكرانيا يجب ان
تشمل الاعتراف بضم المناطق الاربعه
الجديده جاء ذلك ردا على سعي اوكرانيا
لعقد قمه للسلام في الامم المتحده خلال
شهرين
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا ننتقل الى ما يحدث داخل القرم
وهناك روسيا تمنع اطفالا من العوده الى
منازلهم بعد ان امضوا وقتا في مخيم صيفي
في شبه جزيره القرم هذا ما افادت به صحيفه
ديكارديان التي نقلت معلومات عن هؤلاء
الذين ما زالوا محتجزين هناك ويبلغ عددهم
100 طفل على الاقل في حديثها لصحيفه
البريطانيه قالت ناديه طبعا ناديه هي ام
اوكرانيه مقيمه بمدينه خرسون قالت انها لم
ترد ابنها البالغ من العمر 14 عاما منذ
اكثر من شهرين بعد ما ارسلته لمخيم كان من
المفترض ان يمكث فيه لمده اسبوعين فقط
فبالنسبه لها كالعديد من الاباء في خرسان
تعتبر نادي هذا المخيم في القرم وجهها
صيفيه رائعه للاطفال كونه يطل على البحر
ولكن الان تم منعه ابنها من العوده الى
خرسان والسبب سياسي حسب ديكاردين تحررت
مؤخرا على يد القوات الاوكرانيه في نوفمبر
ولكن بالنسبه لروسيا ما زالت تابعه لها
تقول روسيا ان سبب منعها الاطفال من
العوده الى الاراضي الاوكرانيه التي كانت
تسيطر عليها موسكو هو من اجل سلامتكم لكن
لمنظمات حقوق الانسان الاوكرانيه راي اخر
يشير الى ان هذه المخيمات الصيفيه تستخدم
لاعاده توجيه الاجيال القادمه بقصد محو
الهويه الاوكرانيه وفقا لديكاردي ان تزعم
السلطات المواليه لروسيا في القرن انها
انفقد 19 مليون دولار في عام 20 22 على
معسكرات الاطفال التي تم الترويج لها عبر
المدارس في المناطق التي سيطرت عليها
روسيا سابقا على انها تقدم مزيجا من
الترفيه والرياضيات والفنون
هذا واقل المتحدث باسم الكربلاند متر
بسكويت قال ان روسيا لم تتشاور مع اوبك
بلس بشان رديها على تحديد الغرب لاسعار
النفط الروسي مشيرا الى انه من حق روسيا
اسياد الرد على النحو الذي تراه مناسبا
لمثل هذه الاجراءات غير القانونيه
اخرى تتعلق باسواق الطاقه فان الجانب
الروسي بطبيعه الحال من خلال نائب رئيس
الوزراء المشرف اليكساندر نوفاك على اتصال
دائما مع دول اوبيك بلاس اذا كانت العقود
تحتوي على اشاره الى سقف سعر معين فهذا
بالطبع غير مقبول ولكن اذا لم تكون هناك
روابط لصق في السعر فلن يتم تطبيقه سوق
الغازي له خصائصه حاليا يتم تحديد الوضع
وبعد ذلك بالطبع بعد اكتمال تحليل سيتم
صياغه مزيدا من الخطوات في الوقت الحالي
من السابق لاوانه الحديث عن ذلك
طبعا كان الرئيس الروسي في لدمير بوتين قد
وقع مرسوما بحظر بيان النفط والمنتجات
البتروليه للدول التي تقر حدا اقصى لسعر
بين بيع الخام الروسي ابتداءا من فبراير
بحسب القرار يستمر حظر التصدير لمده خمسه
اشهر تنتهي في الاول من يوليو المقبل كان
الاتحاد الاوروبي ومجموعه الدول السبع
الكبرى قد اقروا فرض حد اقصى لسعر بيع نفط
الروسيه عند 60 دولارا للبرميل وفي سياق
اخر تستعد اليابان لاستيراد اول شحنه من
النفط الروسيه بعد توقف عندما اكثر من
ثمانيه اشهر وستكون الشحنه معفاه من سقف
السعر وعلى الرغم من الانضمام اليابان الى
حلفاء غربيين اخرين في فرد عقوبات على
روسيا بسبب حرب اوكرانيا الا انها لم تتخذ
اجراءات صارمه بشان النفط والغاز الطبيعي
في الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
افغانيات يروينا معاناتهن بعد قرار طالبان
منع النساء من العمل والتعليم الجامعي
ومع هذا لسه تعرف كيف تختار
حليب المراعي الطازج الفرق بيدين الامهات
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه انتشر فيديو
لاعبه الشطرنج الايرانيه ساره خادم التي
خلعت حجابها في دوره دوليه وكنا مشاهدينا
تحدثنا طبعا عنها في نشرات سابقه بالايام
الماضيه لتكون ساره خادم الاحدث من بين
رياضيات ايرانيات عده ظهرنا في منافسات
دون ارتداء الحجاب منذ بدء الاحتجاجات ضد
النظام الايراني في سبتمبر الماضيه
عشيه اداء الحكومه الجديده اليمين
القانونيه نقلت صحيفه تايمز وفي اسرائيل
عن وزير الدفاع في الحكومه الاسرائيليه
المنتهيه في ولاياتها قوله ان بلاده طورت
قدرتها على ضرب منشات النوويه ايرانيه وان
اسرائيل تستعد لاحتمال هجوم على ايران كما
قال جانسي ان سلوك المتطرفين في حكومه
نتنياهو سيفرد ثمنا باهظا على اسرائيل
في غضون ذلك نشر مركز الما للبحوث
والتعليم المختص بشؤون الامنيه
الاسرائيليه نشر صورا من الاقمار الصناعيه
تظهر ثلاث سفن تابعه للحرس الثوري
الايراني محتشده قرب مضيق هرمز واشار
المركز الى ان ايران قد تكون مستعده
لاغلاق مضيق هرمز بهذه السفن التي نشر
مركز الماء مواصفات لاحدائها
الى ذلك اعلن رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
المكلف بنيامين نتنياهو تعيين احد مساعده
في حزب النقود يو اف جالانت وزيرا للدفاع
طبعا هو عسكريه سابق شغله منصب رئيس
القياده الجنوبيه في الجيش تولى منصب وزير
البناء والاسكان ومنصب وزير استيعاب
المهاجرين من المنتظر ان تؤدي الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الجديده غدا اليمين القانونيه
في افغانستان قدم ثلاثه عشره استاذا
جامعيا من بينهم سبع نساء استقالتهم من
جماعه كابول وذلك طبعا احتجاجا على قرار
طالبان باغلاق الجامعه امام الفتيات كانت
حركه طالبان قررت تطبيق قراراتها بحظر
تعليم الفتيات في الجامعات فورا اذ منع
حراس مسلحون مئات الشباب من دخول الحرم
الجامعات كما تم طردهن من المدن
وما زالت اصداء قرارات حركه طالبان بمنع
النساء والفتيات من العمل والتعليم
الجامعي تتوالى ردود فعل دوليه واخرى
اماميه تمدد بالقرارات في الوقت الذي
تعاني فيه النساء العاملات في مجال
التدريس الجامعي من تضييق اجبرهن على
البقاء في المنازل
لم تمنعها قرارات حركه طالبان بحق المراه
من المثابره كغيرها من الفتيات منعت بارشي
المحاضره الجامعيه الافغانيه من مواصله
مهام التدريس لتبقى حديثه المنزل وسط
كتبها واوراق العمل التي تابى ان تطوى
كصفحات الماضيه
او انسانيه بموجب المرسوم الجديد لا يمكن
للمراه ان تواصل واجباتها وانشطتها
وبالتالي لم يعد للمراه مكان في افغانستان
وهذا امر مخيب للاعمال
بين جدران منزلها تحاصر خيبه الامل
المحاضره الافغانيه لكنها تنتظر انفراجه
قد تاتي من خلال ضغوط ومناشدات المجتمع
الدوليه
على عدم التخلي عن المراه الافغانيه
ونسيانها يجب عدم معاقبه النساء
الافغانيات بعد الان ويجب عدم الحكم عليهن
بالسجن
اما اشكال حصار النساء في المجتمع
الافغاني فتتزايد يوما بعد الاخر دوريات
المسلحه من قبل اعضاء الحركه المتطرفه في
الشوارع تواجهها اصوات نساء تمردنا على
رجعيه السياسات طالبا
علي السمان العربي
[موسيقى]
عبد الله نادر اهلا بك عبد الله بدايه كيف
هي ردود الفعل ردود فعل طالبان وتعاطيها
مع الاستقالات الجماعيه من قبل المعلمين
والمعلمات
نعم الانتقادات وتستمر
والاذانات كذلك
تستمر واستقالات عدد من الاساتذه
الجامعيين كذلك تستمر في هذا الصدد وال
الاذنات الدوليه
وهنا داخليه كثيفه في هذه
الابنه فقد ندد حامد كرزه الرئيس السابق
لافغانستان في في مقابله مع الوسائل
الاعلاميه الامريكيه هذا القرار واعتبره
مؤسس مؤسفا ومقلقا الحركه لحد الان ليست
هناك تصريحات في هذا الصدر الا ان ارجى
كلمه همم تداولها الاعلام المحلي هي كلمه
الذبيح الله مجاهد بان همم بان المدارس في
بعض المقاطعات المفتوحه وستفتح في
المقاطعات او في بقيه المقاطعات همم
الرئيس همم تنتهي الحركه من وضع المناهج
التعليميه وكذلك وضعي
الاستراتيجيه الامنيه يبدو ان نقاشا حادا
همم يدور داخل همم حركه طالبان فهناك عددا
كبير منهم يؤيدون تعليم المراه تعليم
الفتاه الافغانيه سواء كان في المدارس
الابتدائيه والاعداديه والثانويه وكذلك في
الجامعات همم بحسب اخر تقارير همم تفيد
بان طالبان
تناقش هذه هذا الملف وان زعيمه طالبان امر
بالتشكيل لجنه همم
تفحص او تمحصه المشاكل الاقتصاديه
والتعليميه والامنيه في هذا الصدد وان هذه
المدارس والجامعات ربما تبدا لدى اطلاله
في فصل الربيع الذي يحل بافغانستان بعد
ثلاثه شهور وفي هذا التوقيت يبدا العام
الدراسي في افغانستان
ولكن عبد الله حتى ذلك الوقت يعني ذكرت
ردود الف على مستوى السياسي ماذا عن
المستوى الشعبي الابتعاد يتركز فقط على
الاساتذه في الجامعات ام انه همم الرجال
بصوره عامه داعمين للمراه الافغانيه هل
بالامكانيه همم ربما رصد نسبه هؤلاء
الدافئ ناس فعلا داعمين للمراه لكي تعود
الى ان كان العمل او ان كان الدراسه
السؤال الاهم هل ستثنى هذه الضغوطات
والانتقادات والاذانات الدوليه والداخليه
الطالبان عن قرارها لحد الان طالبان مصره
على قرارها اما الذكور او الطلاب الجامعي
كذلك نددوا بهذا القرار وهم خرجوا في
جامعات مختلفه في مقاطعه مختلفه في
احتجاجات همم ضد هذا القرار ولكن لحد الان
ليست هناك تصريحات من طالبان ومن قياده
العليا التي تنتظرها همم طالبان العاديون
همم ينتظرون اوامر من هذه القياده العلم
هو ليس هناك
مستجداتنا مستجدات في هذا الملف في
العمومي هناك الفتيات الجامعيات من
الجامعياته يقومن بالاحتجاجات والتظاهر ضد
هذا القرار وكذلك همم الطلاب الجامعي
يشتركون في هذه التظاهرات الاحتجاجيه
مراسل العربيه عبد الله نادر شكرا جزيلا
لك
في الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
رئيس كوريا الجنوبيه يدعو الى الرد على
استفزازات كوريا الشماليه
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه شدد رئيس
كوريا الجنوبيه على ضروره ان يكون الرد
تجاه اي استفزازات من كوريا الشماليه ردا
انتقاميا وقال في تصريحات نقلتها وكاله
يونها بالكوريه قال انه لا يجب الخشيه من
سلاح كوريا الشماليه النوويه والرد بشكل
فوري على اي ممارسات تهدد امن بلاده جاءت
هذه التصريحات عقب اختراق خمس طائرات
مسيره من كوريا الشماليه لاجواء الجاره
الجنوبيه كما قدمت وزاره الدفاع الكوريه
اعتذارا عن فشلها في التصدي لهذه المسيرات
هذا وقد اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الكوريه
الجنوبيه ايضا عن اعتزامها لانفاق 440
مليون دولار على مدى سنوات الخمس المقبله
لتعزيز قدرته على صد الطائرات الكوريه
الشماليه بدون طيار خصصت الوزاره الاموال
لاربعه مشاريع تهدفوا الى تعزيز قدرات
مكافحه الطائرات بدون طيار بما في ذلك
الطائرات المحموله جوا والتي تعمل بالليزر
لتدمير الطائرات بدون طيار وجهاز التشويش
لتحديد الاجهزه الصغيره
وبالمقابل استرد الزعيم الكوري الشمالي
كيم جونغ اون اهدافن غير محدده لتعزيز قوه
بلاد العسكريه العام المقبل خلال اجتماع
اللجنه المركزيه للحزب الحاكم حسبما افادت
وسائل الاعلاميه
[موسيقى]
الى تايوان الان حيث ممددت السلطات الخدمه
العسكريه الالزاميه وفقا ما اعلنت الرئيس
التايوانيه انجوين التي اكدت على ضروره
التعداد بلادي لمواجهه تهديدات الصين
المتزايده
اكثر من مناوره عسكريه وتاي ون تفهمها
جيدا تدرك تايبي حجم التهديد ان وقع
المحظور
تزداد وتيره المناوره الصينيه العسكريه
رسائل تريد لها بكين ان تكون قويه وشديده
ام تيبيه فترد تدريبا وتسليحا اخر
الاستعدادات للاسواق تمديد الخدمه
العسكريه الالزاميه من اربعه اشهر الى عام
واحد بدايه العام 2024 غير ان الجيش
التايواني يواجه صعوبه في التجنيد بدوام
كامل وبالاحتفاظ بالعسكر لقله الحوافذ
الماليه طيبه لا تملك الا ان ترد بتكثيف
تدريب جنودها وتعزيز الدفاعاتها بزياده
المشتريات من الطائرات المقاتله والصواريخ
المضادات للسفن
لكن هذا ليس كافيا بحسب خبراء ففي حال
وقوع نزاع فان تعداد الجيش الصيني الذي
يبلغ مليون جندي وتفقه العسكري يتجاوز الى
حد كبير عديد الجيش التايواني الذي يبلغ
88,000
الا ان تلك المقاييس قد لا تعني سيطره
عسكريه صينيه في ما لو قررت غزوه يون
فسيناريو روسيا في اوكرانيا ما زال حاضرا
الواضح ان بكيل لا تتردد في ارسال رسائلها
المباشره ترد على استفزازات وعلى تواطئ
بين واشنطن لا بل وتصاعد فالتدريبات
الصينيه الاخيره هي الاكبر منذ ان زارت
رئيسه مجلس النواب الامريكي نانسي بيلوسي
اغسطس الماضي
حان اتصال هاتفيه من وزير الخارجيه الروسي
سرجيله بروف بحثها خلاله العلاقات بين
البلدين كما بحثا اخر التطورات المتعلقه
بالازمه الاوكرانيه وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه اكد لنظيره الروسي مواصله دعم
المملكه كافه الجهود الدوليه الرميه الى
حل الازمه الاوكرانيه سياسيه
عالميا ازداد مع قرار بكين تخفيف القيود
باضافه طبعا الى فتح باب السفر من والى
البلاد تاتي هذه المخاوف مع ارتفاع في
اعداد الاصابات بشكل كبير
السيناريو الاشد وطئه على العالم قد يتكرر
العوده الى مربع 2020 كورونا لم ينتهي بعد
وتحوراته الجديده لم تبدا ايضا
فصيله تواجه موجه كبيره وتسجل مقاطعه عند
اصابات بمئات الالاف يوميا وقد تصل الى
مليون حاله يبدو هذا واضحا هنا في
المستشفيات ودور الجنازات يقول بعض
الاطباء ان المستشفيات تستقبل اعدادا اكبر
بخمسه الى سته امثال الى عدد المعتاد
معظمهم من كبار السن
ازدادت مراجعته المرضى من الحالات الحرجه
بشكل كبير حيث تجاوزت 500 زياره يوميا
اعتدنا على الفئتين الاولى والثانيه او
الحالات الحرجه التي تمثل 10 الى 15% من
الاجمالي لكن الان يمكن ان تصل ذروتها الى
40%
[موسيقى]
خصوصا بعد تخفيف القيود الصارمه المتعلقه
بالسياسه ركوفيت ولعل فتحه باب السفر اكثر
ما يقلق خصوصا بعد استئناف الصيني اصدار
جوازات سفر وتاشيرات جديده ما يعني موجات
مسافرين من الصين واليها
من المتوقع ان ترتفع اسعار التذاكر على
المدى القصير بسبب زياده الطلب
نعتقد ان بعض الاماكن في اسيا ستصبح وجهات
شعبيه في البدايه تليها اوروبا وامريكا
والعالم باسره
قرار ردت عليه الهند واليابان وماليزيا
بتشديد القواعد على الصينيين القادمين
فيما تدرس الولايات المتحده اجراءات
الممثله
رفعت التدابير يعزز من احتمالات ظهور
سلالات جديده مختلفه عن مشاهده العالم في
السنوات الثلاثه الاخيره ولعل الافتقار
الى بيانات التسلسل الجميل للفيروس يصعبه
على مسؤولي الصحه العامه اي حددوا اي
متحولات جديده محتمله ومواجهتها
البعض منهم ملايين الاصابات وما لا يقل عن
وفاه المليون حال يوميا في الصين العمل
المقبل
اصدرت منظمه الصحه العالميه فيها بشان
وجود دفعه ملوثه من منتجع 50 ملغم في شرق
المتوسط واكدت المنظمه العثور على الدفعه
الملوثه في اليمن ولبنان بعد ظهور اثار
ضاره على اطفال مرضى يتلقون الدواء
المستخدم في علاج السرطان وامراض المناعه
اجرت السلطات الصحيه في البلدين اختبارات
على العبوات المختومه المتبقيه وكشفت
نتائج الاختبارات عن وجود بكتيريا الزائفه
الزنجاريه وهو ما يدل على تلوث الدواء
انطلقت مبادره تسمى بفريق نايل عام 20 18
بهدف جمع المخلفات من مجرى النيل وفتحت
باب جديد للرزق للصيادين المصريين في
محاوله للحفاظ على المظهر الحضاري للنهر
يوجد في هذا الصياد المصري في وسط مياه
نهر النيل في مستهل رحله لم تعد فيها
الاسماك صيدا ثمين فحسب فكل ما يلتقط من
النهر باب رزق جديدا حتى ولو كانت بعض
القوارير البلاستيكيه التي تطوف على السطح
كهداه مبادره ليست جديده حيث اطلقت عام
واستمرت حتى يومنا هذا تفتح باب رزقنا اخر
للصيادين وتسهم في الحفاظ على المظهر
الحضري للنهر عبر تنظيف مجراه من المخلفات
البلاستيكيه وتوعيه الناس بخطوره هذه
المخلفات
وبرده السمك في النيل احنا صيادين والسمك
في النيل جل جل من القزاز اللي كان بيبقى
مرمي في النيل يمين وشمال وعلى الجناب
فبرده السمك جل وبرده مفيد ان احنا بننظف
النيل
يعني احنا الصيادين بالسيدات كلنا على بعض
ممكن نوصل لغايه 100 لكن احنا متخدم او
بنحافظ على النيل 100 مليون وعايزين ننشر
الوعي عشان كل المصريين يكونوا معنا فيري
نايل بس اينما كانوا في المحافظات يكونوا
جزء من باري نايل حتى بروحهم واستهلاكهم
اليوم يقل ويلموا زباله من النيل لو
شافوها وهكذا يسلم والصيادونا كل هذه
المخلفات البلاستيكيه الى مركز المتخصصا
لاعاده تدويرها ويقوم باعطائهم مبلغا
معينه من المال مقابل كل كيلو جرام واحد
من المخلفات التي تسمم النهر وكائناته
الحيه
وتتراوح المخلفات بين 10 اطنان
شرطان في الشهر الواحد في الصيف مقارنه مع
نحو سبعه اطنان في كل شهر من اشهر الشتاء
للصيادين السمك تقريبا
عددهم 65 صياد سمك دلوقتي اا
بيجمعوا المخلفات وبيستفيدوا ماديا
واقتصاديا من سعر البلاستيك اللي احنا
بنينه عدت هذه القوارب بحصاد اليوم من
البلاستيك الدار في محاوله لان تبقى صوره
لبراقه كما تبدو بعدسات الكاميرات من بعيد
ادى سوق الاحوال الجويه في الولايات
المتحده الى الغاء عدد كبير من الرحلات
الجويه في عدد من المطارات الامريكيه ما
تسبب في تكدس المسافرين في المطارات
وفقدان عدد كبير من حقائب السفر
[موسيقى]
هذا هو بينما تواصل فرق الاغاثه في ولايه
نيويورك جهوده انقاذ من تقطعت بهم السبل
جراء العاصفه الثلجيه المميته التي تضرب
الولايات المتحده نجحت سلطات تويوتا
بانقاذ كلب بقي عالقا ليوم كامل على حافه
منحدر جبل مغطى بالثلوج دعونا متابعه
[موسيقى]
وهذه وقفه مع ابرز احداث سبتمبر لهذا
العام
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وبهذا نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه الخامسه
نلتقي مجددا في بانوراما الليله مشاهدينا
[موسيقى]